Welcome to Ear Biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time,
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett, this
week at the round table
of dim lighting, we are wrapping
up the season, the 2021,
something we don't
really call them season,
but we're wrapping up
Ear Biscuits for 2021
by encapsulating the top 10 moments
of each of our lives well, in 2021.
Yeah-
So the top 10 moments
of the year in order.
In reverse order.
In reverse order, counting
down from the top.
I love this episode, it forces us-
You don't know how bad it's gonna be man.
To stop and-
You're saying you like
this category of episode,
this episode may be a train wreck.
You don't know what's gonna happen.
Well, I know what my 10 are.
You could have an allergic
reaction to that jacket.
You haven't worn it very much.
I don't know, anything could happen.
I have a good feeling right,
'cause I like to reminisce
and I think it's very healthy
to put things in perspective.
As I've prepared for this,
I actually experienced
the positive benefits
of kind of zooming out
and having a perspective on this year.
So we'll each alternate
starting with our number 10
and culminate in our number
one moments of the year,
and I think this is a very healthy thing.
Even if there's painful
or negative parts of it,
these are not, they don't all
have to be positive moments.
Well, mine are.
Okay, and we should say
that, like you said,
this is our last episode.
We will be back with
fresh, new 2022 episodes
starting on January 10th of that year.
Yeah, which I guess is
also the first episode
of Good Mythical Morning, season 20.
What is it?
Season twenty-what?
I don't know, the next season of GMM.
We'll be celebrating the
ten-year anniversary,
10 years of Good Mythical Morning so-
I got quite a week plan.
Don't sleep on it.
That second week in January,
we're coming back strong.
One of the things we talked about
as we were getting independently
putting these lists together is,
the comment I made to
you was man, it's not,
honestly, it's kind of difficult
to come up with 10 podcast
worthy moments, now.
If you'd feel that way about this year.
Once I dug into it, I realized, okay,
well actually I ended up having
to take some off the list
and I got to 10 that I feel good about.
But a lot of the things
that I was thinking about
when I actually went back
and looked at my photos
and looked at my calendar,
it was like, oh, that actually
didn't happen at 2021.
Like, oh, that was the end of 2020.
Yeah, 2020 definitely
blurred into this year.
Yeah and 2021 flew by,
and we were getting back
into a lot of things and traveling more
and kind of getting more
normal than we were in 2020.
But man, it's.
Not quite normal enough.
Yeah it's still not normal.
And you know what,
I'd like to just get
started with my number 10,
because I think it plays
right into what you're saying.
Okay-
So my number 10 meaningful moment,
my precious moment of 2021 moments
is now wouldn't that be cool though?
Christy would just go nuts.
Do they still make him?
I don't know she doesn't collect
them anymore and she did.
she could probably get sponsored by him.
Just in life.
Just saying.
My number 10 is getting
my first vaccine in March
and I'm not trying to go political.
What, no, do it, go political
right from the start.
I don't even want to-
Vaccines aren't political man.
Exactly, and that's why
I'm not going there,
even though somehow that's exactly
where we still are as a country.
But this was in March and
it was a milestone out,
Lincoln and I drove together.
We signed up and we did a
drive through vaccination
and there was so much buildup to it.
When am I going?
When can I sign up?
How's the app gonna work?
What are the requirements?
We've been through so much of when 2020,
and now we have this miraculous vaccine
that happened miraculously quick and-
It was just suspicious really quick.
It was just a moment.
Joke, it's a joke.
Come on now.
It's a joke.
Stay with me, I'm trying
to, this is about me.
Okay.
I just really had a sense that that moment
that I was living history
and that's what I was telling Lincoln.
We're living history now,
we're getting history shot into our arms.
We're getting injected with an era,
a time that people will always refer to.
Now tell us about all the side effects
you've been suffering from all year.
Yeah, I have not gotten COVID.
I haven't gotten it.
Yeah, this is not on my list,
but I'll piggyback off of.
'Cause, it wasn't at a moment for you
to get the freaking vaccine,
'cause it represents so much,
that we've been through-
Well here, this is what
I remember thinking.
So, I've gotten a lot
of vaccines in my life,
because I'm a person who lives
in the 21st century, right?
And this is sort of what
we do to address disease.
And we've always done it this way,
but all of a sudden it
became the mark of the beast
this year for reasons that
I don't fully understand.
But I remember because
so much had been made
of how I've never been
scared of a vaccine.
I've never had any
hesitation about a vaccine.
It's always been an afterthought.
It's like, oh, you're
gonna get this vaccine.
You gotta get this vaccine
to go to this country.
You gotta do this, whatever,
it's just, you just go in
and you get it and you
feel a bit weird for a day
and then it's over, right?
Because so much focus has
been put on these vaccines
and, oh, it's a new technology.
It was rushed and all
the media is in this,
Bill Gates is trying to
control you and all this stuff.
None of it that I believed.
I found myself at Dodger
Stadium when I got my first dose
of the Moderna Vaccine is what I did.
The first dose that you're in this,
you don't even get out of your car.
You're kind of going
through the drive-through.
They give you the dose and
then they're like, okay,
wait here for 15 minutes.
Yeah.
And it was basically like,
wait here, 15 minutes
to see if you have some sort of reaction
that it requires an emergency.
I've never had any sense
of worry or concern
but in that 15 minutes, the
first half of that 15 minutes
is when I was like, I started
letting all the information
and misinformation that
had been going around
kind of infiltrate my thoughts
and I was like something's
gonna happen to me?
There's something gonna happen?
Of course, nothing happened
to me and ended up going on.
And then, I got my second dose,
and I didn't even think
about it at that point
and yes, I did get my booster already.
And the booster was just
going into the pharmacy
and sitting down, and he
was like, "Which arm?"
I was like "Left" and it
was boom and I was out.
There was no like, sit
around and see what happens.
It was like, we know nothing's
going to happen to you.
Like very likely that you
might die on the way home
in a car crash, but you're
probably gonna be fine.
But yeah, that first
moment was very significant
because of what had been
made of it in a way that
I've never even thought
about a vaccine before.
Yeah, I just thought of it
as, we're making history here,
and this is something that
will always be talked about
and in making it my number 10 moment,
it represents something larger for,
yeah like you were saying for 2021,
things started to open up,
especially when you got fully vaccinated.
From a work perspective, I think
at least for the two of us,
not for our entire team, by any means,
but for us, our work
lives approached normal.
Like they're not really
normal, it's kind of hard
to remember what normal was pre-pandemic,
but we kind of got back
into work to a point
and engaged to a point
where we're very busy
and it continues to ramp up,
but there wasn't in congruency.
If that's a word between our
work lines really ramping up
and our personal lives
still kind of being stifled
by the pandemic.
And again, a lot of that still continues,
but this is my moment to memorialize
all of the steps that we went through
and all of the little
moments of the first time
that you go out to dinner
outdoors with your family
and you're taking your
mask off at the table.
And it's like you start to
have these strange feelings
that whole swaths of
humanity never go through.
And of course, we're fortunate,
and it's still very serious.
Even this morning, Christy told me
that some of her parents' friends,
a friend passed away from COVID,
like she found out about it yesterday.
This is not something in
our rear view mirror, sadly,
but let's leave it at that,
but yeah, here we are
at the end of this year
and still part of our lives
and we'll continue to be.
My number 10 does tie
in a little bit to this,
because it's, and again,
this is gonna be the case
for a number of the things on my list.
And so for many of the points on my list,
and I would assume the
same is true of yours.
There's a podcast episode from this year
that basically goes into
detail about this thing.
Yeah, maybe if there's a little space,
you have a different
perspective or an update or not.
Well, this one is my trip to San Diego,
my family trip in the spring
to San Diego, which is,
when I talked about it on your
biscuits earlier this year,
I talked about the moment of the Locke
and Shepherd and I being
able to surf together.
Oh yeah.
And how that was just like
a super special thing,
it was like Shepherd kind
of getting the surfing thing
down a little bit more for the first time,
but also me and like being
able to surf together
and actually kind of getting a party wave,
like surfing next to each other on a way
with the first time we had ever done that.
That's a moment man,
you can close your eyes and just see it.
So that's sort of the moment
from that greater moment
that I really remember, but
in the context of the nature
of the way our lives have been,
that was the first
family trip that we took.
I think it was the first real travel
that we had done since the
beginning of the pandemic.
And it was also the first
sitting down at a restaurant
in San Diego, well, sitting an outdoors,
but it was the first time we went back
and even did outdoor sitting at that time.
'Cause I remember that
because when you told me,
we had been on a beach vacation too,
and we hadn't done that,
we just ordered in and I was jealous,
and I was like you should've
told me you were doing that,
maybe that would have
put me over the edge.
But everybody's in their
own little timetable
of like, what you're comfortable with
and you make your own decisions.
Yeah obviously, as I've
established very clearly
multiple times on this podcast
that I take the pandemic very seriously,
and I'm obviously preaching the vaccine,
get vaccinated the best way
to get out of this thing.
But when it comes to my
own personal level of fear
about COVID is actually very, very low.
Like I don't have, like,
I don't have this like-
Anxiety.
Jessie has some anxiety about it.
I don't, I'm just like, man
okay, yeah I've been vaccinated.
I've been boosted, I could still get it.
It's probably won't effect
me, but maybe it will,
like I don't obsess about that.
I'm was about a lot of, I
don't obsess about that.
I remember specifically as
sitting down at a restaurant
and I'm just like, man, I'm
glad I'm at this restaurant.
I'm taking my mask off when I'm eating.
Yes there's like this family over here
within 10 feet of us who's also eating.
And Jesse was like, wow,
they're pretty close to us,
and I'm like, I can't
live, I just can't do it.
I can't live like that with
a constant preoccupation
with it, because I just,
I take the precautions,
and then I let the worry go away,
because otherwise, I just
can't function as a person.
Yeah, it is that thing of like,
if you'd never been on a flight
or if you've never been in a car before,
you're very keenly aware of,
or if like, and I'm thinking
about this for Lincoln,
if you're like getting
your driver's license,
you're keenly aware of
how close you are to death
with someone coming
across that center line.
And then at a certain point
you put every wise practice
in the place and you
just get on with driving.
And if you being reoriented
with the severity
of the risk every time a car passes you
as if it was the first
time it was happening,
you would be durability.
Right, you don't snap your
seatbelt thinking about why.
You just do it because
you've made a decision,
and it's better to just always do it
and just don't think about it.
And I think this year
has been just the slow,
methodical baby steps towards
gaining a comfort level
with COVID strains,
being a part of the news
and a part of reality and saying, okay,
I am doing everything that I can,
and I am getting on with my life.
We still have weekly tests here.
We still have limited
crew coming into work.
It's still very frustrating
for a lot of our crew,
and I feel for them because
they're in positions
that are different from ours,
where you just can't be quite as engaged.
And so we're all on these
different timetables,
and it's not the same across the board,
but I do think that these moments,
they're all COVID impacts
every area of our lives.
And at a certain point, but
you just get on with it.
Well you do if you're
lucky, you get on with it.
If you're lucky.
There's a lot of people who can't
maybe it's just, specific
like auto-immune thing,
or maybe it's just the anxiety,
listen, we're still in the midst.
That's a different timetable yeah.
We're still in the midst
of a mental health crisis
that we have only scratched the surface.
We really do not understand the level
that society has been impacted by this
and not just disease itself is one thing,
but the anxiety that has
been induced by the way
that this has all been communicated.
I have a lot of opinions about that,
but I think that we're gonna look back
and think about all the
ways that this whole thing
was fumbled by our country
and by the world but-
Let me go to my number
nine, to switch gears,
I chose as a moment, the
Hazel horror TikTok shoot,
I debated between the release
of it and the filming of it.
But I wanted to home and on,
you got me in my head about that in that.
In that context, just so you
know, either one is correct,
but exactly in the way that you used it.
Home is the original correct Version.
I wanted to home in, on the filming of it,
which was back in August,
'cause first and foremost,
we did this for us.
And it was this just the experience
of removing some creative shackles.
Again, for reasons that
we've already talked about,
limitations that we have been under,
and then hatching an
idea that we could take
from start to finish and get
out there into the world,
and there were no gatekeepers.
We didn't have to convince anybody,
we just had to align our team
and so it was first about us saying okay,
we're gonna write something,
we're gonna do something scripted.
We're gonna do something experimental.
We're gonna utilize TikTok,
and we're gonna twist it,
and you got really excited
about the horror aspect of it,
and the challenge of working with TikTok
and then involving our team
and just the creative spark
that comes from trying something
that you don't know
what it's gonna be like.
It was very exciting,
and for me personally,
it jolted me out of a creative slump.
'Cause it's one thing to
not be creating things
outside of the playgrounds that
we work in within the shows
and the properties that are ongoing
and that we found ways to
mitigate within the pandemic.
But it's another thing to say,
I'm gonna do something different.
And I think I had gotten to a point
where there was a creative depression,
and that was a very instrumental period.
I remember when we first
talked about doing it,
I had to make an active decision to say,
I'm gonna engage in this,
and so remembering that
is very encouraging to me,
because it was an instrument
of kind of reopening that
part of my creativity.
And of course, then the payoff of it,
I don't know where you
put it on your list,
or if you wanna talk about
it as a separate moment,
because I'm just talking
about when we went out
and we were working with a team.
We were filming on location
in the woods at night,
and then the creative house,
like, so two nights in a row
pulling all nighters,
switching our entire schedules upside down
and taking the input
of other team members.
It was just a lot of fun to do.
Well it was my number five.
Yeah, and I didn't
isolate it to one moment.
If you're a member of the medical society,
and your present or you
go and look at the answers
to the AMH, you may see
that I said some things about people.
Somebody asked about the Hazel project
and yeah kind of what our
thoughts were about it.
And first of all, let me just
say that this time of year
is just bonkers for us, right?
Every single year, everything
it's very difficult
to communicate exactly
why it gets so stacked up
at the end of the year,
but we've got projects
that we can't talk about.
And we've got just the
aspect of running a business
and wrapping up seasons
and all this stuff,
and it just getting
ready to go home, leave.
And there's some pre taping for things
that are in the new year.
So then there's this, like,
you're living in the future,
you're living in the present
and you're looking back at the year
with like employee reviews, this podcast.
So it's a lot at once, being
pulled in different directions
even in space and time.
Yeah, so it's difficult and
we had an AMA scheduled,
and of course, it was like everything,
most of the time you're around,
it's just like the AMA is scheduled.
There's something before and
there's something after it.
It's just like, what do you have today?
I have an AMA.
Now, I have an AMA in
seven other things, right.
So I wasn't in a great
mood is probably reflected
in some of my answers during that time.
But somebody asked about Hazel
and the way that I talked about it
was in retrospect, it was
a disappointment for me,
because, I agree with
everything that you said
in terms of the fulfilling nature
of being able to create something
from start to finish and put it out there.
But of course, we know that
it didn't end up performing,
compared to like some of
the really dumb TikToks
that we do that take about
four minutes to come up with
and one minute to shoot to
get 10 times as many views,
that was a little disappointing.
We kind of know why that happened,
but then when we put it on YouTube,
it was also kind of like,
eh, nobody really cared.
Now, what I did say is
that I was very encouraged
by all the feedback that we
got from mythical beasts,
and this may have come across.
I didn't mean for this to come across
like an insult if it did.
But I said that in some ways,
I really appreciate all the feedback
from the mythical beasts,
but at the same time,
it's like when your grandparents
come to your school play,
and they talk about how
great of an actor you are.
And you're kind of like,
"Are you telling me that I'm
a great actor because I am
or because you're my grandparents?"
In other words we have-
And if only your grandparents
are the ones telling you that,
it really makes you question.
And so I think this is what I'm saying.
We have a lot of grandparents though.
I see the mythical beast
as our grandparents.
You guys, and thankfully,
this is a privilege.
You have expressed a lot of
love for us and for what we do.
And so we know if we
put something out there
that we've put our heart and soul into
and that we're proud of,
chances are you're gonna like it
and you're gonna appreciate it.
But we're always like,
is it gonna break outside of the bubble?
And the fact that it just
kind of definitively did not
do anything beyond the fan
base was discouraging for me,
especially, and this is
a personality disorder
that I have had, and
probably not a real disorder,
but doing something, and then,
it doesn't get the reaction
in the feedback that you're looking for,
and therefore you, it's a value goes down.
That's something that I'm working on.
Being able to find the
value in the process
and the execution, and
to putting it out there
and having it be
appreciated by just a person
or just be appreciated by us
and that being the end of it.
And then, if it's appreciated
by more people enjoy
by large group of people,
then that's just gravy,
but that's not why we're doing it.
I'm working on that, but-
But it was part of the
reason why we did it.
It wasn't just for the reason
why I put it on my list.
The reasons I gave it was
also to give an experience
to dedicated mythical beasts,
who were gonna be there live.
And we had to get together at
my house, a live viewing party
of the posting and reactions
and it was absolutely thrilling.
That was probably the
best moment actually.
That was the best moment,
because it was special
for those mythical beasts
who were there for it,
who experienced the surprise.
And to see them back in the moment.
And realization of what it was.
And see Shepherd with
a blanket over his head
and just as his eyes
peeking over the top of it,
as he watched us like, oh,
he's very, very scared.
So we engineered it for us,
we engineered it for
dedicated mythical beasts
and we also designed it with the hopes
that it would be talked
about outside of our circles.
And when it wasn't it, yeah,
I think that is a legitimate
disappointment, and it's not related
to any sort of disorder, because
it's what we set out to do
and it didn't happen.
So the fact that you
put it at number five,
even after all that surprises me.
Well, I think it's just in retrospect,
when I think about what it represents.
And I think me putting it at number five.
What does it represent?
No no I'm saying,
I'm trying to have a
healthy perspective on it.
Okay, so actually putting
it at number five.
I'm putting it in number five,
as in hopes that I'm
becoming a healthier person
that doesn't need things to be a success,
an external success appreciated
by people externally
in order for me to give it a high value.
Okay.
Okay we got a lot more to go through.
We do wanna let you know real quick
that these mugs they're going away.
We don't keep mugs around for very long.
This is probably the coolest
mug that we've ever sold.
It's color changing, it's activated.
But yeah, if you want
it, you better get it now
through the end of the year.
Right.
The design is only revealed
when there's hotness in it
and then a different design
remains when it cools off.
This one.
Yeah so that's going away.
We got all new mug coming down the line.
But you didn't hear that here.
Yeah well, but you know,
that's kinda that's happening.
Yes we'll always have a mug, won't we?.
Okay my number nine.
Yeah.
Which I guess is gonna be
higher than nine on your list,
Good Mythical Evening.
Okay, it is on my list, it
is number six on my list.
Okay, okay what a night, man.
People wanted us to talk
about Good Mythical Evening
and we haven't, so this
is us talking about it.
Good medical evening to
me, there was a lot of,
I wouldn't say I was nervous about,
anytime you're doing
something that is like,
oh, this is live.
I haven't been nervous about an episode
of Good Mythical Morning
in years, it's like that.
Okay, if we have a guest that
I'm like, kind of nervous
to be around or something like that maybe,
which that hasn't happened recently.
And there was a few episodes
that demand more of us
from a performance standpoint but-
But something that's live,
that people have paid for.
That we've never done before.
Yeah and so-
And not to mention that it's doing things
we've never done before, like
being out rated on purpose.
And I think we might have different,
I'll tell you why it's on all my list.
To me, yes it was fun to do in the moment.
And I think that, especially
once towards the end,
when Brittany became a part of the show,
you know who Brittany is, if you watch
Good Mythical Evening, there's
very few moments this year,
from a comedic standpoint
that are gonna be any funnier
than when we were trying
to manhandle Brittany
and get her eyes back in and
all that stuff that happened.
It's just like, this is
stuff that you cannot plan
that we can't be, that
we can write all we want
and never be that funny with our writing,
that's the kind of thing that's
gonna happen in the moment.
So I liked that aspect of, but for me,
there's been kind of a very slow,
but gradual process
over the past few years,
with some notable moments
of us shedding another layer
of this persona that people
kind of understand us.
And obviously the first
big thing we pull back
was talking about our
spiritual deconstruction
and saying, "Hey you
thought we were these guys"
but we were those guys a long time ago.
And actually we're not these,
it is conservative
Christian guys that we were
when we started this job.
Yeah.
We haven't been for a long time,
but then being able to do sex timber,
which is, I'll talk about
an aspect of that later,
but like being able to kind of
talk openly about that stuff.
And then it was like,
Good Mythical Evening
came right on the heels of that.
And it was just like, hey, we do curse,
and we do, like, we do
drink these things happen
on a very regular basis in our lives,
but we don't ever share them with you.
So to me, it wasn't just like having fun
in not being ourselves.
It was just like and of course yes,
I can attest to the fact that,
when Lincoln has playing has drink.
I can speak to my experience.
He doesn't always,
it's not like every
time Lincoln gets drunk,
he is the and he wasn't, I'm
not gonna say he was drunk,
but I'm just saying that
like, it isn't like Link
is like that every single
time he has a drink,
but the fact that we were
able to just be ourselves,
that's the thing that I value.
The fact that people appreciated it,
but the fact that it's another
layer of just like, hey,
this is an authentic
revealing of who we are.
Yeah again, I put it at
number six on my list,
and I think a lot of what you said
is at play that I think for
me, yeah, it put it on the list
and maybe put it higher for that reason.
First of all, yes it was a gimmick,
it was a marketing
gimmick in a lot of ways
when we first hashed it was just like,
we had gotten to a point
that we wanted to show
more of our full selves
as responsible adult who could-
Responsible is questionable.
well, just being adults.
Yeah, yeah.
So yeah, it was a
gimmick, but it was also,
like I said, it's an evolution
of our brand to say, hey,
don't unnecessarily put us in
this box that we're not in,"
to never hear us curse.
A box that we put
ourselves in, by the way.
That we built yeah.
We don't wanna stay in the box we built,
we wanna get out of it.
And so it's like, okay, it would be fun
if you really think about it.
These guys curse, we
curse on this podcast,
but let's take that to 11 for a gimmic
to just have fun with it.
But it expands people's, it
changes how they look at us.
It expands us beyond the box
that we've built you're right.
And I would say the other part
of it was, yes, I was drunk,
but I also leaned into
it, it wasn't planned.
So the story is, of course
we had two full rehearsals,
like hours and hours
long were full rehearsals
with the entire crew where we
stepped through everything.
Yeah.
And then we did it again,
once we said, okay,
we're gonna tweak some stuff,
we're gonna fix some stuff
from a technical standpoint,
we're gonna tighten it
and then we did another
like, dress rehearsal.
And then before we actually
did it, of course we didn't,
there was no drinking involved.
It was like, there were segments,
we were gonna be drinking.
And cutting the fool and, we
knew it was gonna be crazy,
but then before we did it,
there was actual drinking involved,
and our discussion ended with,
oh, we'll have some drinks.
And then the thing that I didn't,
you said "You've never
been nervous for something
or like keyed up for it."
The thing that I didn't realize was that
I was a lot more keyed up than I realized,
once I had some drinks,
then what went out there
and the whole crew was
like, ready and it was like,
the adrenaline just started pumping.
And that's when I gave a
speech to the whole crew
and boy, I just really
started feeling buzzed,
like it just like, and it was vey quick
and you were not present for that.
I walked in and people seemed confused.
Everyone had like a
confused look on their face,
I was like, oh, Lincoln,
must've given a speech.
Right, you know the look
when Link has given a speech,
and then there was a
countdown like to going live.
And then like the heart
rate with every step
of the countdown, just like.
This is not my experience by the way.
I was just like, I was
going through the roof,
I was like excited, and so
yeah, when the thing started,
I was an abbreviated.
Yeah we could tell.
And it was dawning on
me, I was like, oh no,
like I knew that we were
gonna drink throughout
and letting in, and I was like, okay.
Or there was some segments
we were gonna drink,
but like, I definitely
wasn't feeling buzzed
really at all, but then
I could tell it was-
You're a big man.
But I was like, oh, no Link
is, and so then it was funny
'cause like hearing Stevie
tell it, it was like,
Stevie was like, oh no,
'cause she's like expecting us
to like hit different marks and stuff.
So there was this
adjustment period for me,
which I think I would
be much better at this
if we were to do it again,
I'm not saying we are,
but if we were to do it again,
of like knowing that like,
I felt this responsibility
to be like, okay,
Link is not going to be a
reliable source of structure,
and so that left it to me
is what I was thinking.
And so I realized, I was
like, okay, no, I don't,
I guess I don't have to do that role.
Stevie's kind of, we're
gonna be responsible then
and think about that and
tell us what to do next.
I would say, I'm not ashamed
of anything that happened.
I'm not ashamed of anything I did,
and I don't regret anything
except for one thing.
And that was that the
way that it happened,
it put you on the ropes
'cause it blindsided you.
I know that the crew was surprised,
but we're in this together
and this was a performance
that we had prepared for, and
there was a give and take,
and I put you in a position
where you had to respond.
But I know you know, that I
didn't do that intentionally,
'cause we had a conversation about it.
I think at the mid point
where there was the one break,
the point where Stevie
came back and she was like,
you got it, can you just
relate it a little bit?
We gotta make sure we can
get through this whole thing,
and I'm like, hey, I got this, I'm okay.
I'm not gonna go off an
actual deep end here.
But my main concern was
it that I was putting you
in a position where,
again, you had to respond
and it was something that I
didn't want to blindside you
and I didn't do that on purpose.
And so that's what I was saying
in the middle of the thing,
and I appreciated your response.
I think you understood that
I wasn't trying to, I wasn't,
I didn't know what was
gonna come across that way,
but as it was happening to
go back to the beginning,
it was like, all right,
I had a decision to make,
it wasn't that I was so inebriated
that I didn't have any faculties.
The fact of the matter
was, I was very buzzed
and I made a decision
to lean into it, to say,
"You know what, we've
rehearsed this twice."
The entire crew, they've got this.
So it became an exercise in
complete trust in our crew
and you, that I had your support
and I'll put it this way.
I actually felt like it was a safe space
for me to just cut loose
and to lean into how I felt.
So that happened very early
and so there were elements
of a performance associated with it,
it was harnessing the
experience I was having
for a performance.
I would say it was an exuberant
expression of letting loose,
but it was an expression of
that, that I felt comfortable
and safe doing that,
not only with the crew,
but also with the audience that was there,
the people who signed up for this thing.
And I knew that, and in the end,
the reason why I'm not embarrassed
or felt the need to
apologize for anything,
is because that's all
it was, nobody was hurt
besides Brittany.
I don't think anybody
was offended or crossed.
Yeah, in which we didn't know.
Because it was all alive.
I've never had a chance to
communicate that to anybody,
I just went with it.
Well, I think the evidence is that
everybody appreciated that,
and at the end of the day.
And it was unplanned and I
found that very exciting.
Yeah, and like I said, I think
the only open question is,
will we do it again?
It's gonna be very difficult to capture
the same thing that happened.
My knee jerk reaction was
I don't wanna do it again
because it's like this
expectation that like,
well, how crazy is Link gonna
be next time we do this.
But with some, having
had some space from it,
I think there's
opportunities to dabble in,
how could we revisit this idea again?
So I think the door is open.
Yeah, I definitely
think it's on the table,
and I think that maybe the
novelty of it having happened,
was broken, the seal is gone,
but the fact remains that
we cannot do and say
those things on YouTube
because the platform doesn't allow it,
you don't get this, we're
going to a different category.
So it is something that we
reserve the right to do,
again potentially.
But yeah, it was an exuberant performance
of legitimately letting loose for me.
And I think that that's
ultimately why I put it
at number five.
Or six.
Yeah I'll it at number
six, was because it was,
and I saw people tweeting
this, that night,
at least one person that
was like, I appreciate
the fact that Link felt
comfortable enough with us,
that he could just let
him, just go with it.
I can't remember how they put
it, but I agree with that.
I think that was my experience.
Well, and I think and
that's where moving forward,
I think I would say.
Maybe it was obnoxious at
times and I will own that.
Well I think for me, it was
I'd be like, okay, well,
just so you know, if
we're gonna do it again,
I'm not the master of ceremonies,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, it's not on me to control
what's gonna happen next
to move things through
logistically, it would be like,
I want to have the freedom to do that.
I didn't feel the freedom to do that
because I felt like somebody
had to keep things tied down.
But if we were like,
Stevie, it's up to you,
and it's all on you
because I'm not gonna be,
I don't like being the straight man.
I hate being the straight
man, So it's just like,
I think that, but that
could be so structureless
that it's just, people can't
even follow it, I don't know,
we'll figure it out.
We don't have to talk
about it anymore now,
we need to move on 'cause
we got a lot more to go,
you're number nine.
Was Hazel shoot, so my number eight
is going back to North Carolina,
visiting family for three weeks.
We devoted an entire
episode to talking about it,
it was the longest I and my
immediate family had been apart
from our extended family since
we moved out to California.
So that was a big deal, and
there's a number of moments
that will stick with us,
meeting Sylvie our new niece
for the first time and
handling all the affairs
of the house and the estate,
after my nanny's passing,
which I believe it was a moment from 2020,
not being able to go home for her passing
and being there in her absence
was a difficult experience.
But one that I was grateful to have
and to serve my family in that way.
So, I had already unpacked all of that.
I think looking forward to going home
and seeing the family
again for the holidays
much shorter time now
three weeks is a long time.
We're doing much less than
that, but it's nice to be able
to get back into a rhythm
of seeing everybody,
moving forward.
The North Carolina trip back
home was number six for me-
Okay.
Like you said, "I got to see
family for the first time
since the pandemic," and I got
to spend time with my family,
the McLaughlin's in the mountains.
And I started talking about
all the stuff that we did,
the highlight from that
was probably like my dad,
my brother and I getting to
play golf together again.
And then spending time with
Jesse's family at the beach
and the incident of escaping
the fire house fire-
Again.
Those are episodes that we
told those stories in detail,
if you have not listened to those,
I don't remember the title of the episode,
but it was in the summer after
we got back from our trips.
Yeah so that was the first flight,
the first pandemic flight.
Yeah.
So the whole idea of like,
okay, I'm getting on a plane,
Gotta keep that mask on.
I'm a mask on, on the plane.
You're not giving us anything to eat.
Yeah and I'm like, okay.
Again, once I take the precautions,
I just kind of, don't like,
okay, there's a guy behind me
who won't stop coughing.
Am I gonna sit here and obsess about this
and be anxious about it the whole time?
Or am I gonna just be like, okay,
what can I do at this point?
Let's just not worry about
it, if you get it, you get it.
But yeah, that was my number six
but since we've told
those stories extensively,
we don't have to spend any time there.
My number eight, which also
did a whole episode about
was my Florida keys trip, glitter boobs.
I remember that was more recent,
having just talked about
it, is there anything new?
Like, are you like, oh, now
I'm going back twice a year,
I gotta get back to those keys.
Well, I miss those glitter keys.
I will say there are just times
when I'm doing anything at all,
when just to set a glitter
boobs just pops into my brain.
I can be just doing anything,
like once you've seen
a set of glitter boobs.
That's not true though, is it?
Yeah there's kind of nothing like him and.
No I do, I am thinking I will go back,
not for glitter boobs, but
just, and oh and by the way,
thanks to all of you who a
lot of people sent messages
with, hashtag your biscuits
about their experience.
I saw that.
And the keys once I kind of told the story
of everything that I saw.
I think the best moment
from that whole trip though,
was the pirate ship, giant
vehicle with the mass
on the pirate ship where
like stripper poles
and people dancing down the
street, that was probably the.
Old white people's thinking wop.
Yes or at least playing wop.
Okay, yeah.
That was the highlight of
that trip and fairly recent,
that was my number eight.
My number seven, it was
a pandemic milestone
that kind of brought closure
to an era of the pandemic
in 2020 Britain and I started
connecting through Instagram
and doing listening parties
where we would make Spotify playlist
under a certain assignment
and we collaborate on
and we present, we build it together
and then we would experience
it live on Instagram,
along with anybody who
wanted to watch us live.
Lily showed up for a couple
of those and contributed
to some playlist, and
there's a lot of memories,
and from the early on in the
pandemic, it moves a lifeline,
and it was something that
I talked about over 2020
and towards the end.
And then in June of this year,
we had one final listening party.
I say final 'cause it's not like we said,
"This is the last one we'll ever do,
but it's the last one that we've done,"
and we don't have any
plans to do it anymore,
but it was in June, the
22nd listening party
and Britain was there
in person in my house.
So it was very symbolic, that,
hey, we've done this thing
where we couldn't be
together in the same space
and now things are
loosening up to the point
that we can be together with a certainty
that we're gonna be safe and
so it was very celebratory.
It had some pretty Good
Mythical Evening vibes to it,
because I was so charged
up just so exuberant
about the fact that like we were together
and there was a lot of symbolism
in it for me at the time
that made it very celebratory,
that people were like
is Link on something?
And what I was on was just
experiencing connection
that we had been waiting
for for a long time.
And I know that a lot
of, with our families
and with friends over
time, over this past year,
we've had some get togethers
where you have that first hug
after a year and a half of not seeing,
or being able to touch
this person that you love.
And that's what that listening
party symbolized for me
and was very special for us
because it was the conclusion
of something that was a lifeline.
And it was the best way to
conclude it is, being in person,
wrapping your arms around each other.
And I know so many of us have
been able to experience that,
so that's why I put that at number seven,
which is the number of completion.
So you're done.
No, I have six other ones,
but isn't that what number seven is,
Yeah it's the complete number for sure,
number seven for me is, Sex timber,
but specifically having Jesse
and Kristy on the podcast,
again, for the reasons I already said,
I think that I always enjoy, I like,
I don't know something about,
I don't know what it is,
but I like being able to
talk openly about things
that I feel like we've held back right.
Yeah-
And there's only so
much of that you can do,
but the whole process of
being able to talk openly
about these different
stages and sort of the way
that we thought about sex
was a really liberating
and empowering just for me personally.
But my favorite moment was
getting the ladies on the podcast
and having them be able to
speak from their perspective,
which I know was a big moment
for them to be a part of that
and to see the way that
everyone responded to that,
of course, there's like so
many people calling for,
"Well, we gotta have the wives
podcast, give them a show."
Listen, if they wanted to
show, they would have a show,
if it was up to us, they'd have one,
it's not up to us, it's up to them.
But I think that, that represents
a pretty significant moment,
and I'm not speaking for
Christy, I'll speak for Jesse.
I think that, they've been
through their own journey
through this whole
spiritual deconstruction
and the worldview changing
over time, on their own pace
in their own way.
Their story is their story, not ours,
Jesse I know being able to kind of speak
from her experience, what
it's like to be a woman
in that particular system in a
way that we can not speak to,
or really even understand,
it's something she talks about
on a regular basis with people
that she interacts with,
is something that she maybe
talks about on Twitter
or whatever, but she's never
kind of coming to our world
and give in, had an
opportunity to speak to that.
And I was able to see how much
it connected with other women
out there, who have similar
stories, or at least can relate
to their story in a way that
they can't relate as directly.
Yeah, it was a cool moment, really,
I guess I didn't put it
on my list specifically,
so I'll just steal it from
your list and 'cause I'm 100%
agree that it was quite a
milestone not to just have him
on the show, but to, but to let them share
their perspectives and that whole series,
I think was very rewarding.
And so that was your number six.
Seven.
No, that was your number
seven, my number six,
as I already said was
Good Mythical Evening,
which again, I think the common
denominator between the two
is experiencing freedom,
actively experiencing being free
at a level here to four
we had not experienced.
Being able to speak openly
about our views on sex
and our experiences past and
present, it's a great feeling
to say, I'm not going to be
held back by what I'm afraid,
people might think about me.
I am going to be myself and
I'm gonna embrace myself
regardless of if other people
do, and Good Mythical Evening
was an exercise of that
for me, and the sex timber
was an exercise of that for me as well.
And it feels good, to experience freedom
when especially when it's a big contrast
from how you've lived a lot of your life
in maybe just in certain pockets,
but to have those pockets
open up is very rewarding.
Yeah, I've already talked
about my number six,
which was the North Carolina trip.
I haven't talked about my number five,
this may sound like a smaller moment.
One just an hour in time,
maybe an hour and a half,
but it's something that
it only happens once
at least with each child that you have.
And so my number five is
Lincoln's first driving lesson
back in January, I kind
of took him off guard
because he didn't have his permit yet.
We just went out to a
parking lot, that was,
so it was still legal.
We weren't on the street
and he was like really,
we're doing this and all the memories
of when I learned how to drive,
when my Papa taught me how
to drive that pickup truck
that he surprised me with for Christmas,
that by the way I remembered,
when I told that story,
it was a little bit different.
You had called me Christmas morning
and we didn't answer the
phone and you left a message
on my answering machine and mom
and I could hear you talking
about, "Hey did you get that
big red four wheel surprise?"
And I'm running over to pick up the phone
because mom didn't know
that you knew, and you knew
because I told you, 'cause I knew
that it wasn't really a surprise
and I didn't want to ruin the surprise
and that's how it happened.
But I remember when I'm
telling Lincoln how to turn
and he's like, like we talked about,
he's like, "I actually don't,
I never realized what it
feels like to push the brake
and turn the wheel and try
to, everything is so awkward."
And it just brought me back to
that moment as a 15 year old
myself in that pickup
truck that he gave me.
And it was a Rite of passage
for him, and for me as a dad,
that he was nervous
even though he was there
in a parking lot and it was awkward.
And he probably had no clue
that it was like something
that was very emotional and
like a real dad moment for me,
so much so that I'm putting
it at my number five.
I have another moment with
Locke that I'll talk about,
but yeah, same parking lot by the way
that I think that was this year.
It's crazy 'cause Lockes,
it feels like Lockes'
been driving forever.
And by this point, but yes, I-
And you don't have to talk my moment.
No, I'm not talking.
You can just go to your moment.
My number five was, the Hazel project,
which we've already talked
about, my number four.
I'll go ahead and, and go my number four.
Okay so we're gonna tell you
in general about a project,
because I can't talk about
this particular week,
that was a highlight of my 2021
without giving you just the general.
And we have alluded to it.
Yeah so in 2020.
'Cause I know what you can talk about.
In 2020, we came up
with an idea for a movie
that we wanted to wright.
Now, we have not, since
gutless wonders back in the day
when we were 14, we've
never written a screenplay,
like we've written TV pilots,
we've written seasons of TV
things like buddy system and books,
but we've never written a movie, right.
And it's just, we like to have
a bunch of irons in the fire
and we had this, what I will
describe as ridiculous idea
for a movie, that we just were like, man,
let's just make this movie like, listen,
we've got this idea for a movie.
Let's just move to the
next phase of writing it
and then when people are like,
"Hey you guys got any movie ideas?"
We're like, yeah, we've
got, here's our script.
This is what we wanna make.
Maybe we can get somebody
to help us make it.
Maybe we can end up
just making it our own.
I don't know how this is gonna work,
but like, let's at
least get to the script.
Let's not just talk,
let's just not get a kick
out of this crazy idea for a movie,
bring it up occasionally and then realize
it's been three years and
all we've done is bat around
a concept for a movie.
And as you might imagine.
let's move this thing forward.
As you might imagine,
given all the content
that you see from us,
whether it's this podcast
or Good Mythical Morning
or Good Mythical More
or everything you see on social media,
everything you see on the medical society
and everything else that's going on.
Finding the time to write
a movie is not something
that naturally presents
itself in our schedule.
So I remember this pie in the sky.
I actually remember we had conceptualized
and even sort of roughly outlined
the movie at the end of 2020.
And I was thinking I
was gonna take some time
over Christmas break of last year
to like get started on the
script, that didn't happen.
Yeah, I almost put down
and I'm not gonna steal
your thunder here with
what you're getting at,
but in September, we did
manage to protect an entire day
to complete an outline of the movie.
Well, so it took until
it took until September
to finished the outline.
And at the end of that day,
or at some point towards
the latter part of that day,
I remember us having a
conversation about how much fun
we were having.
We don't have that conversation enough
where it's like today
was completely creative.
We weren't running a business,
we weren't interacting
with our employees as great as they are.
It was like, it was back to
the basics of just creating
and collaborating, it was
extremely rewarding, especially-
And it was the only day of the whole year,
where that was the case.
Coming out of a creative
depression and then saying,
"We have this day where it's like, hey,
we still can have this experience."
And so that day of outlining
brought us to a point where,
just that day was amazing for
me and then it was like, okay,
now we need to move to writing.
Yeah and so, and I told
Jenna shortly after that,
I was like, listen, I know the stuff
that we've got going on right now.
And I know the projects
that are beginning to happen
and we know how the end of the year is,
we need to reserve a week
where I can go to a cabin.
Yeah, in your mind, it had to be a cabin,
'cause that's where writers write.
And just do nothing but
write and see if I can write
a movie in a week.
You're really talking
about five days by the way.
Yeah five days.
And it might've been just four days.
Because I was gonna get there on,
what did I got there on a Monday.
I went there on a Monday evening.
And then I showed up on the Friday.
Actually you showed up
at Friday at like 2:00 PM
because we had to do
that Facebook live thing
was with Hank green?
So I was like, okay, between Monday night
and Friday mid morning,
I wanna write a whole movie
based on this now again,
there's an outline, so it's
not like pulling things
out of thin air, it's like,
I know what needs to happen
in this scene, but like the
characters have to come to life
and there's gotta be dialogue
and you're gonna end up
writing a 100 pages, right.
And so I was actually like
on, a couple of days before
I was like reading stories about people
who would like bust it
out scripts really fast.
Like there's just stories
of people being like,
I had to get this script stripped done,
and we wrote for four days straight
and we ended up getting it done,
but I've never done this before.
Right?
Yeah.
we talked about it a lot.
Yeah yeah, but I was like,
I wanna have a first draft done.
And I ended up that, even that
first night I wrote about,
about 15 pages that first night,
just to kind of break the seal
and get going on it right.
And then over the course
of the next three days,
I woke up about seven o'cLock,
we start running about 7:30 AM
and would not leave the
cabin, deeming get dressed.
I would just brush my
teeth, I had food with me
and would write until I couldn't see.
'Cause there was no light in this cabinet.
You had an hour house.
And long story short,
things, time began to blur.
There was a couple of
times when I would stop
and I would like read through
it and I would be like,
and I texted you and I was like,
man, I've lost perspective.
I don't have any idea if this is any good.
I keep getting to these
places where I think that
what we've come up with is too crazy,
and then I just don't know
if we should continue,
and if this is like going
to be a huge embarrassment,
if anyone ever reads it.
And what did I say?
It was very profound.
You were like, "That's a really good sign"
or something like that, like
if you're getting to the place
where you think that what
maybe what you're doing
is too crazy, you're
probably in the right place.
So I kept going and when you
showed up on Friday I was like.
You sat there and you watched me read it.
I was like, hey, I have a script, man.
I have no idea what you're
gonna think about it,
but we have a first draft
and again, the first draft,
it didn't like the first draft
is all we have right now,
is a first draft we're
working on the second draft.
I don't know how many drafts are gonna be.
There's a lot of notes, it's
gonna change again but anyway-
But now that we've shared it
with Stevie and with Mallory.
They're not going to
let us go another year
without finishing, coming
up with another draft,
I think in the next month
or so they're gonna hold us
to a second draft, which is their jobs.
Right.
And so it's very exciting, but again,
that made your list so high because why?
Well one of the things I've
talked about with my therapist
is that I find a, like my happy place
is in just a pure creative process, right?
And I get into a creative
flow when writing
where the things just
start coming together
in a way where I know exactly
how I want this character
to be represented in what they
would say in this situation
and how this character would react.
And it feels like you're
kind of reading a script
that someone else wrote.
You just get to a place
where it's just like,
I know exactly how this
character would react.
And I just don't get to do,
that's the thing that I would
do full-time if I could right,
I would just create 100% of the time.
That's just not how our lives work.
That's not the business that we've built.
So it made my list
because I was in the zone
and I was getting to do the
thing that I love the most.
I was reminded that I wish
we could engineer our lives
and our schedules to a place
where it wouldn't have to
be crammed into four days
to write a script in four days.
Right, well, maybe it can one day.
And maybe it Will one day,
so I'm not getting frustrated about it
as much as I'm just being thankful
for the fact that it happened
and it like, once you move that
pushed that giant Boulder up
to the top of the hill, it's like, okay,
now we have the potential
for some real momentum.
So it just because I enjoy so much.
My number four in, once
I get into my top four,
it's tough to order these
in particular order.
So I wouldn't read too much into these,
but I put it number four,
Lily and I making a permanent decision
to get matching tattoos.
Is a moment that's memorialized forever,
and it's extremely special to both of us.
she's back home for Christmas break now
and I see her tattoo, she
sees tattoo, it's like, yeah,
there's like a little, the
connection that we have
is there permanently, unless she like,
well I guess she could
pull a Pete Davidson
and labor the laser those things off.
Or she could just have
an accident with a laser.
A few accidents with a laser
or a one accident with a crazy laser.
But it was, for her to turn 18 this year,
for her to graduate from
college, I mean high school.
And she's had so many
milestones and it was great
to be a part of one that like
is such a headline reminder,
such a visual reminder of our
connection, was so special,
and the fact that it was
her idea was really great.
I'm getting in my top three are similar,
they're all about each one
about my family members.
I will say my number one's about my wife,
but number two and three, random order
whether it's Locke and
Shepherd there a tie
they're both tied for second.
So to my number three, is getting indexed.
I'm gonna get to do this tonight.
when I leave here, I'm gonna do this,
is watching Locke play basketball.
So, he's been playing
basketball since middle school,
and, he transferred schools
to kind of in the mid,
like right at the
beginning of the pandemic,
he literally transferred to a
new school in January of 2020,
and then a pandemic happened.
And so he immediately like, okay, wait,
there's no basketball season.
He was actually playing
basketball for the other school
anyway, so it's like,
didn't have a basketball season last year.
So it's the senior year in high school.
He's at like a small school
where like, you get a chance
you can play, and it's not as competitive
as a school that he was at.
So we're kind of looking forward
to him being able to play,
but Locke does a lot of different things.
And his focus on basketball
was not nearly as intense
as my focus on basketball growing up,
like going into my senior year is like,
there was a few things
I cared about, but like,
you could count them on one hand
and one of them was basketball.
And it was like being the
leading score on my team
and like us being a good team,
like it was like a focus.
And so as basketball season rolled around,
like there was actually a moment
where like right before the
season started, he was like,
"Hey dad I don't even know
if I wanna play basketball
in my senior year,"
I was just like, I have
a lot of other interests.
and I was like, well, "You've
been going to these practices,
like this sort of informal practices
and your team is really
small and it seems like
they've kind of been
counting on you playing,"
and I know his tendency to kind
of move from thing to thing.
So I encouraged him, I said,
"I think it would actually
be a good to just like,
stay with this commitment
and just see this through,
and I think it will be
something you look back on
and be like, I'm glad I
made this decision to play,"
Or at least something that
you put in your top 10.
Yeah.
Just kidding.
No, but honestly, it wasn't this thing
of like a dad wanting his son
to play sports against his will.
It was very much like,
I know Locke so well
and I think it was something
and being committed
to something that's got
some structure to it,
It is a good thing.
And so, they played a couple
of games and I was like,
I don't know how this is gonna go.
They got beat horribly,
the first game I ever went
and like, you could kind of
sorta tell like, oh yeah,
Locke really hasn't been
working on his game.
He hasn't been practicing
and I'm gonna be very
encouraging to him or whatever.
But over the last few games
that I've watched him play,
there's like something
just awakened inside him
and it's like, you can
see the competitive nature
of him come out and it's
just like the other night
he had 33 points and
then he had 29 points.
He hits six threes in one
game, he hit six threes
in the next game, I was like,
oh, he's gonna break my record
of seven threes in one
game if I don't watch out.
Did you tell him he
knows about your seven.
Well he's already beat my scoring record
'cause my career high
I was only 29 points.
Does he know about seven in one game?
You have to tell him.
No he knows it, I've told
him that before though I-
Well don't tell him too much.
But in the other night, they were playing
and they were down by,
going to the fourth quarter,
it was a tight game
and like, Locke just took it upon himself.
He just kinda took the game
over and he had, I dunno,
like five, 15 points in the fourth quarter
and just like making all these shots
and they didn't end up winning.
It was very close, it was very close,
but like, I don't know, it's been so fun-
That would have been a better story.
It's so fun because this is an experience
that I didn't expect to have.
It's like, I've seen him
do things like diving
and that kind of thing
and I was never like,
I'm not putting any practice,
I don't think that he's gonna
be a professional athlete.
I don't think he's gonna
be an athlete in college.
It's more just like, this
is a fun thing to do.
I wanna be supportive, I
want you to have something
that you're doing that
you're succeeding at,
but it's just like, I saw him playing
and I saw how laser focused
he became on winning,
and I was like, wow this is something
that like, I remember what
it's like to be out there.
I didn't know he was ever
going to have this experience
of being somebody who's just out there
and he's, like, I'm gonna
take, give me the ball.
Not like, oh, the pressure is on,
I'm gonna pass the ball to somebody else.
He's like, no, the pressure's on,
I want the ball and I'm
gonna make the shot,
just give it to me.
And so become real, it's
super fun to watch him play.
But there's a connection there.
Oh yeah.
To your past then his presence.
Yeah, and I'm glad that
he gets that experiences
his senior year, he's like,
"I wanna focus on lifting weights"
and I'm like, okay,
lifting weights is cool,
but lifting weights,
doesn't generate memories
in the same way that being on
a team and playing together,
I guess another school does,
it's a different experience.
Lifting weights doesn't,
#EarBiscuits, all you gym bros
out there and gym girls,
whatever you're called.
I'm just saying, okay,
yeah you get a new PR
everything, whatever but I'm just saying
it's a different, thing
than a team's support.
My number three is Christy and I
going on our big search
trip again I'm my top fours,
nope I'm not saying that
Christy's my number three.
Okay well, I'm just .
I know what you said well,
my wife is number one,
but yeah, it was a super
special experience.
The rain and the red woods,
which I talked about pretty recently,
and it was a rescheduling
of our 25th anniversary
after we had already celebrated
our 21st wedding anniversary
and I'll always remember
the two of us in the cabin
with the rain coming down
and it was just about us.
There was nobody else on the
planet and there was no place
that either one of us wanted to be.
And at this point in our relationship,
a lot of people don't
get to experience that.
So I do not take it for
granted, I'll leave at that.
I'm gonna save my number one,
but that's my number one too
not being with your wife in big Sur,
but being with my wife and big Sur.
Well then wait until you're number one.
So I'm gonna talk about my number two.
Yeah that's your next one.
Well but so far when
we've had one coincide,
we've said that so I did-
Well if you have a little space
you could say the same thing
and people might think that.
Well, I'll say something different.
My number two, again,
tied with number three
is this is a general memory
and then I want to talk
about a specific thing,
but it's my time that I spent
with Shepherd one wheeling,
thanks to your idea of
getting the one wheel.
This is your number two?
yeah.
Because of me?
This is your number one?
So does that make me your number two?
Kind of, I made your number two possible.
Well, technically the
company one wheel did,
but yeah, you buying a one wheel,
it was a very good decision
I'm glad you did it and I.
I'll take that, I'm a
part of Rhetts number two.
And the thing is sounded gross
is this specific challenge
with Shepherd is the fact that he,
especially over the
course of the pandemic,
when you couldn't really do anything,
and you're doing all your school online,
he really made a connection
with a couple of his friends
that he knows from real life
and they would play video games together.
Yeah.
And they're playing lots
of video games together.
Yeah.
And I have just a classic
middle-aged dad perspective
on video games,
which is, I think that they
are a total waste of time.
Now I know that that's
not totally true okay,
and I know that video games
are not as bad for you say
as just sitting there and
watching television, right.
They're interactive in a
different way, whatever,
but I just don't want his
childhood to be defined
by playing video games and that's it.
And so when you got these one wheels,
'cause when we will go out
and do some things together,
but it's like, okay, if we're
gonna go surfing together,
it's like that joy, you got to
go all the way to the beach.
We're a long way from
the beach where we're at.
We don't really do the
mountain biking thing
because my kids never
really learned how to bike
in a way that they can go do that
and even if I wanted to, right.
Hiking is hiking, right.
It's worked for a child.
And so the moment we
went over to your house,
when you said, "Hey,
we've got these things
and come try them," and it's just like,
Shepherd has got on him and just did it,
he just got on it and he was gone.
And I was like, okay.
And he's like that when it
comes to those kinds of things,
so it wasn't necessarily a surprise
but the thing that I was
sort of in, excited about,
I was like, cause he said,
"Dad you should get some of
those, we should have those."
And then I got them the
thing we each got one
and he rode it a 100 miles
in the first week on his own
and he goes all over the
place on the thing Right.
I don't even care anymore where he goes,
as long as he's got his
phone with him, just go, man,
live a life, be like a
kid from the eighties.
And a helmet.
Wear a helmet and some pads, if you can,
if you remember to do that
risk guards and a helmet
and a phone and you're good to go,
and then we'll have these days
where we were just like, Hey,
it's Saturday afternoon, let's go.
And just a few weeks ago we
went to just a really special
sort of, there's a lot of like parks
and sort of open recreation,
wilderness areas in LA,
if you know where to look.
And it's one that you've been
to and you had told me about,
and Shepherd had been there
because he has done like a camp
there or whatever, and like
in the, in the same area,
but we went and we just had this day
where we were going on these trails
and we just kept stopping and
like literally saying things
that you would say in like
an afterschool special,
which is like, I'm
having such a good time.
Don't do drugs, dad.
Yeah and both of us kind of
realizing how good of a time
we were having, and like he will do it,
even if he's in the middle
of like one of these quests
on one of his games where this boys,
if I'm like Shepherd one wheel,
he's like, guys gotta go
hangs up and we go right?
It's like, I don't have
to convince him to do it.
He has such a good time doing it.
And he's better at it than
me 'cause he's smaller
and so he's willing to go a
little bit faster, the board,
he can go up things that I can't go up.
So that's a cool thing that
he's like kind of leading
and going in these things.
Yeah, and he'll really, really remembered
if you take him out and
he breaks his wrist.
Well I'm honestly very surprised
he hasn't broken something
yet, it is inevitable.
Referring to the fact that's
what happened to Lando,
his back on it now.
He's gonna hurt something,
but hopefully that won't slow them down.
So that's in general but that
day, just a couple weeks ago,
when we kind of had the
incredible experience
found like these new trails and stuff
and found these new parts of
LA that we didn't know about,
that's been really special.
Yeah, my number two is we had an addition
to our family join us in 2021.
He is golden, in peanut
butter and in color,
but kind of looks like my other dog Jade.
So yeah, Jasper came along
in February of this year
and Christy had been, I was
like, as long as the dog,
I just want another
Jade and I'd love for it
to be a peanut butter Jade
and Christy really wanted,
a dog more than I realized
'cause Jade's my dog,
very loyal to me.
And I remember when she
first showed me the picture,
I was like, this is a peanut butter Jade.
Let's go meet this dog right
now and I I'm pretty sure,
I don't know if I told
the store here or on yeah,
on Good Mythical More
when I introduced Jasper
to the mythical beast, but
there Christy has experienced
a connection with this dog.
Jasper was already a year old
and had separation anxiety
really bad, like the woman
who was the foster mom said,
"I can't put him down, I have
to carry him all the time
because he jumps in cries," just like.
Put him down is probably not
the best choice of words.
Put him down on the floor, I
have to carry him in my arms
and so, yeah, for the very beginning,
Christy had to like cradle
this poor dog who was afraid
of who knows what from his past,
but his foster mom was a blonde woman.
Christy's a blonde woman, the
handoff was very immediate
and the connection that they
have is, it was so much,
I didn't realize the point,
the extent to which Christy
needed that type of connection
at this particular point in the pandemic
and what she was going
through, and so she would say,
"I am so grateful for this dog"
and we all love him to death.
I have this connection with him as well.
He's still like, everybody
loves him, and he's weird
about other family members.
It's taken him a while to warm up,
haven't been almost a year with us,
with everybody except for me and Christy.
But he's brought so much into her life
that it's just been, we can put
up with the fact that, like,
he still has a lot of trouble
with being housebroken.
Oh man, we're having an
issue, we still have issues.
So it ain't all roses in slices of pie.
I will tell you that by any means,
It's like caring for a baby
that you're trying to figure out
and that he's trying to
figure out life with us.
Well I will say when I had to pick,
I had to pick him and Jade.
That's right.
From the dog border, this is a dog border
sounds like someplace like the dog nation.
Whatever the kennel or
whatever you call it and.
The pet resort.
To taking Jasper and Jade
home like as soon as I got,
first of all, when the lady
handed Jade was like frozen,
like she handed him off, he
was just kinda like frozen,
just kinda like his eyes
were like really big, like,
but he didn't growl or anything.
And I just kinda took him
and put him in the car,
but he was in frozen mode with the lady
and then frozen mode with me.
Yeah.
I put him in the car, I start the car up
and immediately he just
jumped into my lap.
And then I'm like, oh, is
this how it's gonna be?
I was like, buddy, you can't be in my lap
because it's against the
law as Christy learned,
you cannot have a dog in your lap.
We have a special carrier now
He insisted on jumping into my lap
and I kept having to move
him to the passenger seat,
and eventually I was like, okay,
it's not that far 10 minutes.
He just sat in my lap
with his head on my arm
while we rode in the car.
And then Jade starts barking at me
because she wants me to pet her.
So, I'm sitting here
driving with one hand,
your peanut butter Jade is in
my lap with his head on my arm
and Jay and I'm constantly petting Jayden.
If I stop for a second,
she barks and growls
and claws at me.
Yeah.
And so I'm just like,
good Lord these Neal dogs
are so needy.
Yeah, it's nice to be needed.
I think is what Christy and I say.
I thought Barbara was like-
No.
Barbara is super needy at home.
She'll bark at you and
stuff like when you drive,
she wants you to pet her a
little bit and then she'll go
and lay down but no, no,
no, not Jasper and Jade,
they're gonna give it
to you the whole time.
I noticed that Socket
did not make this spot.
Well he was added last year.
Oh, okay.
But yeah, we're definitely
warming up to him
and he's found his niche
in the home ecosystem.
But yeah, he's not
gonna make my list here,
but yeah, just to see
that certain kind of love
that Christy needed, that was different
than the kind of love that I can give,
that you can only get from a
dog that adores you like a God,
I guess.
So it's just been super
sweet to see their connection
and for that to be just
a part of really seen
how a connection with an animal
can really be .
Transformative.
It can be transformative
therapy and it has been for her
and so for him to be a
bonafide member of our family
is super special.
Okay, my number one is my
trip with my wife to big Sur,
which was also to celebrate
our 20th anniversary,
which it actually was
our 20th anniversary.
We had originally planned
to go, I talked about,
again, there's another episode
where we talk all about this trip.
So I won't go into too many details,
but we had planned on this
being our 20th anniversary
in Italy, of course,
that kind of travel
didn't happen this year.
So we went to big Sur
and in a similar way,
as you were talking about with Christy,
the level of intensity of our
connection during that time,
was something that we
have, that was the pinnacle
of the intensity of our
sort of singular connection
to each other this year,
it was an incredible,
it's hard to get that
level of connectivity
when you're at home
with kids, with the jobs
that you both have and both very busy.
And so we had the fleeting
moments that throughout the year,
but there was this focus on one another,
and we took a whole week.
We basically were up
there for a whole week
and because we were like,
we're taking a whole week
because we were gonna be
in Italy, but we can't be
so let's just to make it a week.
And we still talk about that
and we made us end up going to big Sur
for our anniversary from here on out.
Probably not because we
like to go to new places,
but we talked about it because
it's a super special place.
And then the type of
connection that we experienced
and the type of, sort of the
level of the communication
that we were able to have and
the clarity of communication
that we were able to have
for that week was just,
one of the highlights of
our marriage, honestly.
And then I talked a little bit about,
sort of the spiritual processing
that took place on that trip.
Once you leave an organized
religion and you're no longer
really a part of a
recognizable faith community,
and there's not ritual
and gathering in a book,
one of the wonderful things
about organized religion
in my mind is the structure in
the community and the ritual
and the practice and
that's one of the reasons
it's so successful and
that the community
communities are so vibrant
because people need that
kind of connection to most,
a lot of people need
that kind of connection.
Now since I no longer believe
in a particular religion,
and I'm now no longer a
part of religious community,
the spiritual processing can
be something that happens
sort of just like in sports
and happens sort of on
an individual basis.
And it doesn't happen
as much in community,
and it doesn't happen as much.
There's not as much structure
and direction to it,
and it can be super
beautiful that week for us,
and a couple of different moments
and just the sort of the
spiritual connection.
And I'm not gonna go
into too many details,
but the spiritual connection that we had
was also kind of feeding into
the just human connection
that we were having
and the love connection
that we were having, and the
way that all those things
kind of played together.
I talked about some of those realizations
that Jessie was coming to,
and she talked about that
on her Twitter as well, but
that was one of the things
that made that special is that,
hey, we go months sometimes
without having a meaningful,
spiritual connection,
in the context of our family.
we have really sweet moments,
we have really loving moments.
We have intense moments of
connection with one another,
but sometimes we don't have
what I would consider spiritual progress.
And to be able to get that,
that week was something
that I greatly value.
That's a good number one, my friend.
Yeah.
My number one, maybe a process elimination
you can figure it out, was
sending Lily off to college.
I devoted an overly emotional
commemorative episode
to unpacking the details
and all of the tears
associated with that,
but just realizing that our
family is different now.
It was a Rite of passage for
her and a successful one,
she's experiencing success
in her first semester away,
or first quarter away, she's back home.
She's finished it up, she's
got that under her belt.
She's doing great, it's
not without its challenges.
It's not without its moments
of being afraid or lonely,
or all the things that you might think
of an experience she's
had tastes of all of that,
but it's been very much a
positive trajectory for her,
which is a huge relief for Christy and I.
But then also realizing
that like our status
as people have changed,
like I have a child
who's, well, I have an adult
child who's out of the house
and when she comes back, it is different.
And I was being very dramatic
about the way that I was
processing it and I enjoy that
because it made it very meaningful.
But yeah, it's like, she
comes back and it's like,
how do you feel being back
home for Christmas break?
She said, "It feels like,
kind of feels the same,"
but I know it really doesn't
and in every way, and for us,
it's like, things will never be the same.
We've crossed a threshold
into a new era as parents
and as a family, and I'm grateful
that it's going so well
for her and for us,
that like, she surprised me.
And when I came home
from work two nights ago
and she was there, she
had moved her flight
and she came back early
and it was like, yeah,
I almost burst into tears
of happiness to see her,
but at the same, but I didn't actually,
I didn't go that far.
It was like, okay, this
is kind of our new normal,
and we're moving into the future
and it's like, every everything associated
with this can't be the
most dramatic thing,
because it will be absolutely depleting.
But yeah, I just feel
like it was a successful
Rite of passage, and for her,
I think it will only
happen once, I got two more
that will have their own
versions of Rite of passage,
but this was the year
that became my number one.
And when she put her hand in that glove
that had all the ants on the
inside of it and stung her.
Right.
When she got to college,
that was one heck of a
Rite of passage as well.
They did that at her college, right.
That's what I do that at all,
She told you but not me,
but you know what I'm saying.
Right?
Yeah.
So that's my number one
and there you have it,
we have no zeros.
That's it, and you got a wreck
that's in line with this.
My recommendation for
you is do the same thing.
I think we made this
recommendation last year,
but I would have liked
to have taken more time,
but just even if it's taking
30 minutes and going back
through your camera roll,
I wrote down every month of the year,
and then everything that was
the beginning of something,
or, I wrote down like probably 35 things,
and I did not think that would happen.
But when you go through, like you said,
go through your calendar, you
go through your photo roll,
you can go through your
email or your journal.
Like all these things
will jog your memory.
And just writing that down
like I have this record
of every year that we've done this,
that I can kind of go back to by month
and more than just the 10 things.
The smaller things as
well, it just mean a lot,
especially when I went
back and I read last year
in prep for this year, a lot
of memories flooded back.
So I recommend you take the
time to do that for yourself,
and then if you have a podcast,
turn it into an episode.
Yeah, it makes a great
episode, speaking of podcasts,
this one will be back
on January 10th, 2022.
In the meantime, you
probably haven't listened
to every single episode and
you know what it is okay.
If you wanna listen to another podcast.
But we prefer you to just listen
to our archived versions of ours.
Just to make sure it
does not replace this one
in your heart.
#Ear Biscuits to let
us know what reactions
you have to this and we wish you the best
of the end of the year.
Happy holidays, happy new year,
we will see you in 2022.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of your biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.